before we get stuck into our
disagreements let's establish the common
ground which is important otherwise you
can't have a genuine conversation the
common ground is that I we both believe
in democracy
and we both believe in decentralized
Market systems
because the alternative is Central
planning
which I detects the form of God's plan
in the Soviet Union we know how that
ended or amazon.com which is another
form of the Soviet system
in the sense that it is totally
centralized and
the exact opposite of both democracy in
the market amazon.com is not a market
platform is not a market it's a
simulation of a market but not of the
kind that Adam Smith had in mind or any
liberal would have in mind or tolerate
so we agree on that and the the the
struggle to deter tyranny
from rising up
the struggle to prevent ourselves each
one of us because we have a darkness in
ourselves as human beings and whenever
we acquire power this Darkness becomes
more powerful and more Insidious and
more dangerous I think
as true Children of the Enlightenment we
are on that common ground
by the way congratulations on the book
it's a great read you should read it and
highly informative even though I have
covered in my own professional life all
those areas and periods and so on I
learned a lot
the gist of it as I said and I think it
already said Martin is that you
recognize that
call it what you might liberal
Democratic capitalism is the best of all
Alternatives but it is also broken and
needs to be fixed
and you have ideas of how how to do this
so the big question is and I think this
is also reflected in the title should we
fix it should we abandon it what should
we do about it
now
here's where the the differentiation
between our views begins
imagine this where 1776
here in London
and we're having a conversation about
the system that prevailed at the time
which we now call fidelism they didn't
call it freedomism right
I wanted to it it was still considered
uh along the lines of fidelism and
imagine there was a whole conversation
about how to civilize it
um
that conversation would have been
besides the point
Because by the 1770s feudalism was on
the way out
there was already a very powerful
economic and social Force called capital
that was replacing land as a source of
value-added and Power
and that led to the conflict between the
aristocracy and the bourgeoisie the
merchant class and to some synthesis
which is
liberal Democratic capitalism
the I didn't choose 1776 randomly
it was a year when Adam Smith published
his Wealth of Nations
the whole point about that book was to
say that there is
this transformation historic great
transformation the words of karpolani
taking place
and the old was being jettisoned by
forces that nobody really understood
and this is why Adam Smith's book became
such a great
bestseller because things were happening
that people had no clue of how to
explain them you had
a new class emerging that was extremely
powerful
economically but for the first time
economic and political power were
differentiated whether it had split up
up until then if you had political power
you were the prince the baron the king
you also had economic power but at some
point you have this these Merchants that
are scum in the eyes of the aristocracy
but they have more power more money in
the aristocracy so there was a need to
explain how the rise of capital and the
usurpation of land and the replacement
of ground rent by profit
and capital accumulation was changing
the world I feel
this is my conviction and that's why I'm
finishing a book now that he very kindly
mentioned this coming out September
um I feel that we are at a similar
juncture
that capitalism is being
undermined
and replaced
by a new socioeconomic motor production
which is highly problematic very
interesting fascinating huge challenge
for Humanity
uh
and who is the Agent of Change
in the 1770s it was Merchant Capital it
was capital accumulation it was Capital
the Agent of Change today is again
capital
it's not the left the left we have faith
spectacularly at transforming the world
when we did transform the world we made
the mess of it and then we just went to
ground and we are now in Europe my party
is at four percent increase as a labor
party is not even trying anymore under
case don't transform anything except
themselves so
um
it's capital capital has produced in my
view
a mutation of capital I call it Cloud
capital
algorithmic Capital the tech companies
yes but not so much of the camp it's a
new formula allow me just very quickly
to explain what I'm saying Capital the
way we understand it is a produced means
of production anything that's been
produced in order to produce other stuff
whether it's a steam engine and
Industrial robot a 3D printer if you
produce something to produce other stuff
that's a produced means to production
Cloud capital is a produced means of
Behavioral modification
so you know preaching discussing
advertising marketing is an attempted
behavior modification but when
the behavioral modification
the agent of it is capital Machinery an
algorithm
which is in a dialectical conversation
with people in their own homes over the
phone and so on Alexa you know Amazon's
Alexa what exactly is Amazon's Alexa
it's a machine that trains you to train
it
to train you to train it to train it
to convince you to buy stuff through
first impressing you with fantastic
proposals as to what you should buy and
then sells it to you using the same
algorithm
bypassing the market VA platform that is
a kind a new kind of algorithm I'm
fascinated that you've identified the
power of the algorithm in quite that way
because having radio last book I've
obviously haven't read the new book I
imagined one of the points I wanted to
make to you is
does the power of the algorithm and the
way in which it sucks our attention does
that make it much harder to persuade
people to engage in the kind of society
in the kind of political change that you
envisage or imagine in that book
uh not necessarily I'm I don't want to
be pessimistic and I don't want to have
this surveillance capitalist view that
you know big brother is here and
our minds have been hijacked I'm talking
about a new form of capital which
creates
a new feudalism up in the cloud because
if you think about it today you've got
millions of producers producing apps for
Apple for Google for Facebook uh stuff
that physical products that they sell to
Amazon and when you get it from them
they pay or you pay or together you and
the producer pay 30 percent
of a ground rent to the owner of the new
land which is a cloud
and so we are
Martin's in his book he talks about the
interior capitalism I think now we've
moved Beyond it okay it's not capitalism
anymore it's a kind of cloud rent
feudalism